[Music]
dear Zoe
I have memories of you from before you
were even born
[Music]
[Music]
hey Em
can I see
what is it
Santa lying face down crying
something has changed in the way this
has nothing to do with Zoe everything
else does
what's going on is your mom okay
can I come in
really glad you're here
yeah me too
why is she here at least the custodial
parent not you huh not you
put that kid in there
he's obviously hurt
[Music]
I'm your big sister I was supposed to
protect you
are you coming back home I need some
time I just I have to clear my head
YouTube
tell me that you feel this way
I'm Tess I'm Jim
you're insane this is insane it's my dad
finds something I know that guy
[Music]
go get my act together
focus on being a parent
can I kiss you baby
yes
is it cool if this one knocks off early
I love you I love you too let's fly
your mom and me we managed to do one
thing right you were funny and loud and
sweet and I will never ever forget you
love always
[Music]
teach me how to drive oh
scary words
it's right up there with uh where the
babies come from
[Music]
foreign